lunch time did he hate me no no I'm glad
that was on camera
I hope the microphone picked it up I
don't know why you came
there's a naked man in our cabin good
morning
it's early and we're going to San Juan
Puerto Rico
so we're gonna go on a cruise and the
line that's when New Year's away quick
breakfast
hope they don't miss their place and
then pop our fruits around the Caribbean
islands
here we go Berto rico portrait therefore
look how sunny it is find a half into
the cruise ship
well an unexpected start to our cruise
this is a naked man in our cabin so
let's see what happens so while we wait
for our room and the guy to get out they
gave us a drink credit so we're gonna
have what are we gonna have option B I'm
feeling this but let's try one nut you
gonna steal friend holy cow
we like this Kendall was a stronger
though stronger than that they can sit
down with your husband
you haven't really eaten so you know
you never come around
we're hungry we're getting some food all
that alcohol right down my drink I
downed it out their little boozy play I
get some food Nina's hungry before she
gets angry you need to feed her all
right our first meal is with the view
look at that view and Nina wanted to eat
healthy and be live live a healthy
lifestyle so what's what are we eating
is our first meal we've got two kinds of
rice and two kinds of pasta
we're gonna work it off and I went with
pasta rice mashed potatoes and a hot bag
we are starving and we're gonna eat okay
round two is a little healthier a little
healthier Nina's got some salad and I've
got some salad with some french fries on
top
how's the soup
what is it it's all the same friends
daily trivia that's Vivian's are
questions that you have to try to answer
we're staying true to our policy of
trying to take the stairs whenever
possible except for that first elevator
tiptoes we're hungry we're going back to
the cabin cousin Tina's getting tired
she hasn't slept and we have to have
dinner in
an hour and a half so you gotta rest up
Brenda we just had an insanely good
lunch okay Nina slept a little bit so we
missed our dinner because this is to go
early which nobody told us about so what
kind of upset especially me I'm more
upset I mean there's pretty relaxed and
chill we really gonna buff pay for
dinner which I'm not happy about because
they're rushing us to go to the
mandatory
mandatory safety drill which were not
going to vote Caribbean not going to
your mandatory Joe are not not happening
that what is exciting is watermelon soup
and ice cream with topic
maybe salad strawberry ice cream with
caramel sauce and white chocolate chips
okay no went on a little bit of a rant
back there but the strawberry ice cream
is actually really good so I'm happy
mostly to didn't film anything else
yesterday because in the pasta at 6:30
at night and woke up at 9:00 from
breakfast this is one hour time to print
that's why everything is messed up so we
miss breakfast with everyone get a
buffet okay we're gonna hit it for lunch
we're gonna hit it for line chicken and
not get messed up by the time anymore
all right breakfast outside what's Dina
eating baby food eggs sausage tomatoes
bananas and I have Raisin Bran sausages
hash brown and fruit that's our view
Betty
I don't know why you came you behind
one for lunch because all we do is eat
so partly I'm worried about the internet
transfer I had seven and a half of gigs
of video to send a cocina yesterday and
it's only transferred out fifty
megabytes of it so far
so yeah that's gonna be fine let's see
what happens lunch time are you happy no
so we're done lunch
very cool very cool Susie this we're
gonna walk around thank you block off
some of the action
in the need for daily Sudoku we made a
pit stop in the cabin and I came out of
the wash it when found Nina already
asleep in bed maybe not asleep not in
bed
how come you're sleeping Nina wake up
okay wake up wake up we lay down for how
long three hours someone will you sit
for three hours so we're gonna work out
yeah no gonna do something special first
then work out then get ready for dinner
because it's a formal night so we have
to cruise right after and we told
everybody at the wedding that we want
you to write a wish for us and a wish
for yourself in the bottle and then on
our cruise we would throw it into the
water so that I would go off the sea
like a message in bottle but then we
forgot to bring the bottom with us in
the house for a year and a half so when
we put the cruise the first thing I did
was put the bottle find it in the drawer
and packed it so this is us
commitment to everybody who came to our
wedding thank you for the great message
put yourself in for us and we're gonna
send it off into the water so for all
the healthy people are in the gym we're
doing the ellipticals machine is angry
if I'm not holding on to it
where's Nina Thank You Nina
hired Brad a shape I know okay shower
makeup game change dinner I'm in salsa
all right it's dinner time formal night
so work that stuff we're not gonna miss
dinner today you know we are kind of
late Nina took extra time getting ready
it's come to the time they meet
how is it oh hello
super full because we have time before
the show there she is and then look at
the bent elephant we'll name the
elephant Nina okay so after dinner we
went back to the room and passed out
again and even got changed we missed the
show
americo's you be dissin dancing
so we did the salsa competition with him
in third place okay
there's heavily biased but it's okay we
had fun because we weren't from cause
everybody noticed in Puerto Rico
regardless of the talent but it's okay I
was thinking of filming it but they
didn't know where to put the camera but
kind of sucks thank you I'm glad that
was on camera it's 11 o'clock we're
gonna get some pizza then we gonna wake
up really tomorrow morning for our first
stop Barbados good night